my dreams
is
um
[Music]
five
[Music]
my heart
just one time
you
[Music]
with
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
my heart will go
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
me
oh
[Music]
when i say
[Music]
let me
[Music]
tell me
oh
[Music]
[Music]
tell me
is
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
what is it
[Music]
take your protein pills and put your
helmets on
[Music]
control
mission and maybe
[Music]
is
[Music] [Applause]
now it's time for me
is made to come to ground control
i'm stepping through the door
today
[Music]
my name is
we love bright sides
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
there is a house
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you set us back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
jelly children
[Music]
[Music]
misery in the house
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
and you are
[Music]
wow
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
so
all right
so
that's
is
[Music]
guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
and then it is
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
mistakes
oh
[Music]
to be
uh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
my friend i'll say
[Music]
a life that's full
i traveled east and
every highway and
more than this
i did it by
then again too
to mention i
did what i had to do
saw it through without
exemption
[Music]
more much more than this
i did it my
way yes
sure you knew
when i fit off more than i could choose
[Music]
and i stood called
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i find it
[Music]
to think i did all that
and may i say
[Music]
oh
for what is a man
what has he gone
if not himself
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
it's not easy
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
just
yes
[Music]
just feet
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
just
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the vice president
of the united states
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
oh virginia
congressman rob whitman republican
chairman rich anderson
my fellow republicans my fellow
americans it is great to be back in the
old dominion state
and we're just 39 days away from another
great victory for the american people
but i'm here for one reason and one
reason only
and that is that virginia and america
need four more years of president donald
trump
in the white house it's on virginia
and the road to victory runs right
through the tidewater
you know four years ago a movement was
born
a movement of everyday americans from
every walk of life
here in the tidewater you knew we could
be strong again
you knew we could be prosperous again
all of you said yes to president donald
trump in 2016
and i know that virginia's going to say
yes to four
more years of president donald trump
in 2020
[Applause]
four years ago we inherited a military
that had been hollowed out by
devastating budget cuts
an economy struggling to break out of
the slowest recovery since the great
depression
terrorism was on the rise around the
world and we witnessed a steady assault
on our most cherished values
but standing here just miles from the
largest
naval base in the world
i'm proud to report to you under
president donald trump
we've rebuilt our military
we restored the arsenal of democracy
and this president signed the largest
investment in our national defense
since the days of ronald reagan
including the largest pay raise for our
military forces in more than 10 years
and close to home hampton roads under
this president
saw three additional navy ships
stationed here
adding 25 000 military personnel
contractors and their families to this
community
bringing the economic impact of the navy
to more than 16
billion dollars
but beyond the investment i have to tell
you
as the proud father of a united states
marine
and the father-in-law of a pilot in the
united states navy
i couldn't be more proud to serve as
vice president
to a president who cares so deeply about
the men and women of our armed forces
under president donald trump we are
finally giving our soldiers sailors
airmen marines
and coast guard the resources and the
support they deserve to accomplish their
mission
and defend this nation
we're doing it and with that renewed
american strength
we've taken the fight to radical islamic
terrorists on our terms
on their soil
joe biden and the last administration
oversaw the reckless withdrawal of
troops from iraq with isis capturing an
area the size of pennsylvania
under our commander-in-chief the armed
forces of the united states
captured the last inch of isis territory
crushed their caliphate and took down
their leader without one
american casualty
[Applause]
and where joe biden sent pallets of cash
to the mullahs in iran
president trump got us out of the iran
nuclear deal
gave the order to take down the world's
most dangerous terrorists and qasim
salamani is gone
so we've stood with those who serve
and we've stood with all of you who wore
the uniform of the united states
when joe biden was vice president
america
saw years of scandal at the va that
literally shocked the conscience of the
nation
but under president donald trump we
signed the most sweeping
reforms of the va in 50 years
the va now has a 90 percent approval
rating
and veterans choice is now available to
every veteran in america
[Applause]
and under this president in our first
three years
there's three more ways you can describe
it
it was jobs jobs jobs
where joe biden wants to raise taxes our
president cut taxes across the board we
we rolled back federal red tape at a
historic level
unleashed american energy fought for
free and fair trade
and in our first three years businesses
large and small
created more than 7 million good paying
jobs
including 164 000 jobs
right here in the commonwealth of
virginia
and you know none of that would have
been possible without the strong support
of republicans in congress
like congressman rob whitman and north
carolina's congressman greg
murphy
thank you man but that's also
rob will tell you that's also why we
need
to send these congressmen back and we
need to send scott
taylor and nick friatas to a new
republican majority on capitol hill we
need to retire
speaker nancy pelosi once and for
all
[Music]
the road to a republican majority runs
right through virginia
true so we've stood for our national
defense we've stood with our veterans
and for jobs and opportunities and
president donald trump
every day of this administration has
stood for the rule of law
this president has appointed more than
200
conservative judges to our federal
courts at every level
including justice neil gorsuch and
justice brett kavanaugh
and i can tell you
i can tell you those more than 200
federal judges are all men and women of
integrity
who will uphold all the god-given
liberties enshrined in our constitution
like
the freedom of speech the freedom of
religion and the second amendment right
to keep and bear arms
now this week we mourn as a nation and
honor the life of service of justice
ruth bader ginsburg
the constitution of the united states
provides
that the president shall appoint judges
to the supreme court
and i promise you come this time
tomorrow
president donald trump will do his duty
and
will nominate a principled conservative
woman
to the supreme court of the united
states
and after the senate fulfills their duty
to advise
and consent we're gonna fill that seat
[Applause]
so we've stood for the rule of law every
day
and president donald trump has stood
with the men and women who serve on the
thin
blue line of law enforcement and we
always will
the president and i know what all of you
know
men and women who serve in law
enforcement are some of the best people
in this country
and they deserve the respect of every
american
every day
now the president and i will always
support the right of americans to
peaceful protest enshrined in the
constitution
but rioting and looting is not peaceful
protest
burning businesses is not free speech
violence against law enforcement like
you saw in virginia beach this summer
will not be tolerated and those who do
these things will be prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law
now for months all joe biden never
talked about was peaceful protesters
as the american people watch businesses
and our communities literally burn
the truth is joe biden would double down
on the policies that have led to
violence
in america's cities now joe biden says
that america
is systemically racist
and that law enforcement is in his words
and i quote
has an implicit bias against minorities
when joe biden was asked whether he'd
support cutting funding to law
enforcement he replied
yes absolutely
but i'll make you a promise under
president donald trump
we're gonna back the blue we're not
gonna defund the police not now
not ever
we're going to have law and order in
every city
in every state in this nation for every
american of every race and creed
and color so help us god
so we rebuilt our military we revived
our economy we stood for our liberties
in law
and order and in three three short years
we made america great again
and then the coronavirus struck from
china
but i'm proud to report to you before
the first
documented case of community
transmission within the united states
even happened donald trump did what no
american president had ever done
he suspended all travel from china the
second largest economy in the world
and saved american lives
joe biden said that the president's
action was quote hysterical
and xenophobic but as the leader of the
white house coronavirus task force i can
tell you firsthand
president donald trump's actions saved
untold american lives
and it bought us invaluable time to
stand up the largest
national mobilization since world war ii
we reinvented testing we saw it in the
manufacture and delivery of hundreds of
millions of medical supplies to doctors
and nurses
across the country we've been developing
medicines from the outset of this
pandemic that are saving lives today
and we are on track as i stand here
today
to have the first safe and effective
vaccine for coronavirus before the end
of this year
that's what leadership looks like
the thanks to the cooperation of the
american people the extraordinary work
of health care workers at every level
we're slowing the spread we're
protecting the vulnerable
we're saving lives and we're opening up
america again
in fact because of the strong foundation
that this president poured because of
the unprecedented support
that he secured from the congress after
losing 22 million jobs at the height of
this pandemic
we've already seen 10.6 million
americans go back to work including 188
000 people right here in virginia
so we've gone through a time of testing
but in 39 days we're coming to a time
for choosing
the choice in this election has never
been clear
and i think you all know the stakes have
never been higher
i mean think of this contrast in the
middle of a global pandemic
joe biden wants to raise taxes by four
trillion dollars
president trump he cut taxes across the
board for working families and
businesses
and we're going to keep cutting taxes
for four
more years
joe biden wants to bury our economy
under an avalanche or red tape
even got his own version of the green
new deal
president trump he actually signed more
laws cutting federal red tape than any
president
in american history and we're going to
keep on shopping
for four more years
joe biden is for open borders sanctuary
cities
free lawyers and free health care for
illegal immigrants
president donald trump has made record
investments
in border security supported our customs
and border patrol
and ice and we've already built more
than 300
miles of a border wall on the southern
border of the united states
and with four more years we're going to
build it all
no we're building it
and when it comes to international trade
joe biden has been a cheerleader for
communist china for decades
i mean half of our international trade
deficit when we took office was with
china
we were losing 500 billion dollars a
year
joe biden said that china wasn't even
much competition for america
president trump he put china on notice
on
day one and said the era of economic
surrender is
over we impose tariffs and we will stand
strong until china opens their markets
and respects
american private property and american
workers
and when it comes to values joe biden
and the democratic party support
late-term abortion
and joe biden supports using taxpayer
dollars to pay for abortion
all the way up to the moment of birth
and i can tell you from my heart i
couldn't be more proud
to serve as vice president to a
president who stands without apology for
the sanctity of human life
president donald trump is the most
pro-life
president in american history
i mean when you look at their agenda
it's clear
joe biden would be nothing more than a
trojan horse for the radical left
now joe biden said at their convention
that democracy is on the ballot
well i believe that our economic
recovery is on the ballot
i believe the law and order are on the
ballot
but i also believe there are things much
more foundational to this country that
are on the ballot as well
i mean i can honestly tell you i think
in this election it's
it's not going to be whether america
ends up more conservative or more
liberal
more republican or more democrat
i think the choice in this election is
whether america remains america
[Music]
whether we're going to char a course
based on our highest ideals
of freedom free markets personal
responsibility and our most cherished
values or whether we're going to take a
turn
turn to the radical left and transform
america into something altogether
different
so i want to say to all of you for our
freedom
and all the ideals that have always made
america great we need to decide
right here and right now that joe biden
will never be
president of the united states we're
going to re-elect
president donald trump for four more
years
[Applause]
i mean think about it four more years
means more jobs
four more years means more judges
four more years means more support for
our troops
and it's going to take at least four
more years to drain that swamp
oh we're draining it
so my fellow americans get ready
buckle up it's on
we got a little more than 40 days to win
four more years for president donald
trump in the white house so we need you
to bring it
we need you to reach out to your
neighbors and friends all across this
commonwealth and all the friends that
you have all across this country
bring this same enthusiasm keep voicing
your support
tell your neighbors and friends all that
we've accomplished
and what we can do with four more years
of president donald trump in the white
house
you made the difference in 2016
and the american people will make the
difference again in 2020
you know in all my travels across this
country from big cities to small towns
over the last four four years i can tell
you firsthand
america is a freedom-loving nation
and america is a nation of faith
so as you go forth from here and as you
listen
to my friend tonight
i want you to have faith
have faith in the best days for america
ahead
have faith and confidence that the
american people every time they've been
presented a choice between a future of
more freedom and less freedom
the american people choose freedom every
single time
and lastly if you're of a mind to bow
the head or
bend the knee from time to time in the
next 39 days i encourage you to do that
too
in a time where it seems like there's
more division in this country
than any time in my lifetime i'm
absolutely convinced
that if his people who are called by his
name
will humble themselves and pray
he'll do like he's always done in the
long and storied history of this country
he'll hear from heaven and he'll heal
this land
this one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all so pray for america
it'll make a difference
ladies and gentlemen i got the feeling
somebody just arrived
so i'm going to get out of the way but i
got to tell you
i've served alongside our president
shoulder to shoulder for the last four
years
and i can tell you i can tell you
president donald trump is the real deal
he's a man who says what he means means
what he says
he never quits he never backs down
and he has never stopped fighting to
keep the promises that he made to the
american people now it's our turn
to fight for him
and i'm just absolutely convinced if all
of us
do all that we need to do between now
and november 3rd with your continued
support
with you giving voice to all that we've
done and all that we have yet to do
under this president's leadership
we're going to have a great american
comeback
we're going to have a great american
victory we're going to make virginia and
america stronger and more prosperous
than
ever before
with president donald trump in the white
house for four more years
and with god's help we're going to make
america great again
again thank you all very much
god bless virginia and god bless the
united states of america
[Music]
over new york
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
dreams
one kid feels good
[Music]
might be
yesterdays
[Music]
[Music]
your stomach
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
tv
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
yes
trees
so
[Music]
it's so many times
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
is
is
oh
[Music]
is this
[Music]
[Music]
your eyes
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
god
[Applause]
again
[Music]
[Music]
is
goodbye everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the river
nobody loves me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
thank you
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nothing really fun
[Music]
[Music]
you're always on the run now
don't be careful
[Music]
is
[Music]
i think
[Music]
in oh hands
[Music]
oh
ladies and gentlemen the 45th president
of the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
[Music]
next to you
[Music]
god
[Music]
from the lanes of minnesota
to the heroes of tennessee
across the plains
from detroit down to houston
[Music]
is
where it is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
thank you very much hello newport news i
know it well
i don't
i know it well you know
uh my father and i had a couple of
little jobs here and they were great
when the ships came in
they were packed when the ships went out
they were stone
cold empty and i said this is a
different kind of a place
but we loved it and it's a great place
and i'm thrilled to be back
in the commonwealth of virginia with the
thousands of loyal
hard-working american patriots
and i also want to thank the great
people of
north carolina who's here from north
carolina
not bad it's a little area there
39 days from now we're going to win
virginia
we're going to win north carolina we're
going to win four more years in the
white house and keep doing what we've
been doing because it's never been
anything quite like it
this is the most important election in
the history of our country
one of the biggest issues for the people
of virginia is your
second amendment
[Applause]
and if sleepy joe biden wins your second
amendment will be eliminated and your
firearms
will be confiscated
whether you like it or not when asked if
a biden administration was coming after
your guns
biden replied yes it's all he had to say
yes
he promised to put the gun grabber beto
o'rourke in a bitto
beto remember beto
he was on the cover of a third-rate
magazine and he said
i was born to run for president that was
the end of his run
that's what it ended any time they say
they were born to do it they got
problems that didn't work out it was a
steep
drop but he put bato in charge of his
assault and your guns and you know what
happened with beto beta went
crazy he wants to take your guns away
biden vows to impose
punishing taxes on gun owners outlaw
many of the most popular firearms in
america
create a national gun registry
and wage the most aggressive war on gun
rights
in u.s history
biden will disarm law abiding americans
at the same time they'll have riots down
your street and that's just fine that's
okay
that's okay according to the left wing
only by voting for me
can you save your country and can you
save
your second amendment
[Applause]
so i was told not to go for virginia we
did really well last time and i never
came i never did anything and we did
really well i said
why didn't i go for virginia but it's
traditionally not
a republican state over the last number
of decades
and i said why not you have a crazy
[Applause]
governor
and every time i see it every two weeks
he's trying to take your guns away right
and he'll attack constantly
right to life and you know he's so far
left he doesn't even talk about
late term he talks about after the baby
was born
which is the first time i ever heard of
that you hear late term
but he said and after the baby is born
we'll start talking to mother
in other words she's talking about
execution of the baby
execution
you have a governor that thinks he's
michael jackson remember his wife's safe
remember he wanted to prove that he was
just dressed up like michael jackson
and that he sometimes thought when he
was young that he resembled michael
jackson i don't think so
and you remember he wanted to moonwalk
across the stage
and his wife said no no don't do it
don't please darling
nobody moonwalks like michael
that would have been good i wish i could
have seen that that wouldn't appear that
would not have been pretty
so based on your governor and based on
the fact that he's always
you know every like month you're
fighting for guns
if i'm not here your second amendment is
gone and i'm talking about all over the
country forget about
just virginia so i said let's give
virginia a shot
we're nearby we're nearby
i even said we'll bring in the heavy
artillery we'll bring in our great vice
president
mike pence
[Applause]
did he do a good job
i'll tell you what kamala kamala
is no mike pence she's no mike pence
now he's great he's done a fantastic job
and he's with you all the way
so i said let's give it a shot and
you know there's a big difference i tell
you what there's never been
a bigger difference between candidates
or parties never been
no party that supports as an
example what he would do to a child
after it was born
is fit to be even involved in any way in
this nation let alone running this
nation
as you know sleepy joe biden
endorsed your governor so that means he
endorsed the policy of your governor
that means
that means he endorsed he endorsed
breaking up your second amendment so
it'll either be
totally broken up or it will be you know
wiped out
essentially it won't be that much
different so here we are in virginia
like
[Applause]
like i had nothing to do today i woke up
at six in the morning i read some papers
so
i read the fake news and
and then i was in florida early in the
morning and then i went to florida and
we did a big round table with the
hispanics they were great
[Applause]
and then we flew to atlanta from florida
palm beach and then we flew
we started off in all different places
we were all
and then we flew we went to miami we
started off
but i'll tell you what florida's great
we're going to win florida we're way up
in florida
way out
[Music]
even a poll that gave me i mean i've
never had a good number abc
washington post ball it's a terrible
poll always been bad
i think it got everything wrong four
years ago they said i'm four up
or more but i'm four up in the state of
florida
so anyway so we went to miami
went to a beautiful place actually a
miami you know where that is
and we had we had i won't say because
then they'll say i'm advertising if i do
that
i won't say i won't say the name of the
place
but it is beautiful and then what
happened is we
went to atlanta and we
so we left the great hispanics we call
them the latinos for trump
latinos
where we are polling at numbers that i
guess no
republican has ever pulled before
perhaps abraham lincoln but in those
days
he wasn't big into the hispanic movement
i think
abraham had other things to think about
don't we they
but uh i will say this nobody has done
more for many communities but i always
say for the black community
nobody has done more for the black
community
than donald trump since
abraham lincoln nobody
so we flew to atlanta and we had
an unbelievable two hours
and this was with the african-american
community the black
community i always say what do you like
better tell me what you like better they
say usually the black
community and what is the answer
tell me african-american i'm not
listening i don't want to hear from
other people i want to hear
african-american what do you like better
african-american or
black community it's black yeah that's
what we hear
i'll go with whatever you want that's
your choice we can use either one
i'll go with whatever you want we had
really a great we had a great two hours
incredible people herschel walker
introduced me serious
serious guys
we had a lot of champion fighters a lot
of great people
it was an amazing time and then we flew
to washington
where we had a round table and then i
say well that's it for the night right
you know this starts at
six in the morning so i said that's it
for the night is that it i'll go back
home to the white house no sir
well i wonder what you're going to
virginia sir oh god
oh that's good thank you very much this
was like
i asked a question about an hour ago
where am i going now
put me in coach you ever hear the
expression just wind me up and put me in
coach i said where are we going tonight
i said let's go back to the white house
let's see our first lady
and they said no sir you have a rally
schedule
you have a rally schedule where is it in
virginia i said oh that's good
how many people they said a hell of a
lot of people
well i wouldn't i'm kidding i'm kidding
i'm kidding when you have rallies like
this you don't forget them
you know forget them thank you god
[Applause]
so we're going to put a heavy play in
for virginia seriously we're going to
put a heavy play in virginia
and i think we can win the stage man
that crowd is big look at that goes way
back to the hangar that is a big
you know i always tell the cameras i
don't want to bore people with this but
i i implore them turn the cameras around
and show them the size of this crowd
goes back to the building
but they never like doing it because
they don't like including fox they don't
like showing big crowds
you know they don't like showing big
grass
we left ohio we're way up in ohio way up
in ohio
we're way up in georgia we were in
georgia today though with the governor
and
the senator senator perdue we were
[Music]
you know representative doug collins
great guy
kelly loffler great person senator
and uh senator perdue and i said how we
doing
they said you're winning by a lot in
georgia
of course if you see these people
they'll say he's pretty close in georgia
too close to call and then we have
election night comes
the polls in georgia are closed donald
trump has
in the state of georgia you know you
only win if you're up by like a lot
if you're up by a lot they announced it
i mean that was what happened with texas
last time they said texas is too close
to call
all for months and months and months the
only one that didn't believe that were
the people in texas so when it closed
they said the polls in texas are closed
donald trump has won the state like in
the same breath
now we're doing great in texas we're
doing great all over the place we're
doing great all over
i hear where i hear we're up in new
hampshire which is great
last time that one got taken away from
us with uh people that just came in with
buses all over the place
they had buses coming up from
massachusetts
you have the rhino governor you know the
rhino governor of massachusetts that's
right baker
he's a rhino but i guess he does
whatever he can to get elected the
democrat party
is now run by socialists and marxists
who want to destroy our laws
our values and want to destroy your way
of life
to uphold our constitution as written
tomorrow i will be announcing
my nominee to the united states supreme
court
fill that seat oh we're gonna fill it
don't worry about it
and the republicans have been very
unified you see that
very unified even a couple of people
that normally don't vote for with us
usually don't vote with the republicans
but they are
and uh we have tremendous unity in the
party mitch is doing a good job
kevin is doing a good job we're going to
take over the house we're going to take
back the house
people are tired of crazy nancy they're
tired
we want to get some stimulus out she
doesn't want to give it she just doesn't
only be for political reasons not your
fault
you know what's faulted as china's fault
that's your fault for me
that's whose fault but you know uh
it's an amazing thing because the
democrats are saying well it's the end
of a term
and because it you know we have a lot of
time left
think you think of this if it were them
don't forget we don't have to do it by
the election but we should be easy
really able that would be a great
victory going into the election
with that biggest of all victories you
know they say the biggest thing you can
do
is the appointment of judges but
especially
the appointment of supreme court
justices that's the single biggest thing
a president because it sets the tone of
the country for
40 years 50 years i've been a long time
so we're going to be announcing somebody
great i just think that you know there i
just watched
the great thing about air force one
there are more televisions on that plane
than any plane
they got them in every room and you open
up for a closet you want a shirt let me
know about there's a television
and i'm watching the democrats saying
how terrible it is that we're appointing
we have the right we won the election
right that we have the right
we won the election and we have a lot of
time
and if they were in our position they
would uh do the same thing maybe they
would just do it more rapidly okay
more rapidly now so what tomorrow i
think is going to be a big day five
o'clock tomorrow at the white house
we're going to be naming the nominee
hopefully we'll be on that court for
50 years
[Music]
be on there for 50 years the only thing
i can tell you for sure
is it will be a woman is that okay
[Applause]
does anybody have any objections to that
please
please raise your hand a lot of cowards
out there look at you men i don't see
how
there's not one man here that has the
guts to raise your head
not one if given the power of the
radical left
will pack the supreme court with
extremists
who will strike the words under god from
the pledge of allegiance as they did
twice i heard their pledge of allegiance
they had it in their caucus i'm watching
i said oh they made a mistake i said to
the first lady darling
they made a mistake they left the words
under god out
and then i heard it a second time and
they made the same mistake i said this
is straight
this is like the guys on the mueller
team that cleaned their phones
right 31 phones and they said oh we made
a mistake and they all made the exact
same mistake the odds of that are a
billion to one right
they all made oh they got caught did you
see what's going on oh they
got caught see i feel sorry that's a
that's a shame yeah they should be i'll
tell you they
are they should they're crooked people
they're crooked people so they cleaned
up their phones
hillary took her phones and smashed them
she took
33 000 emails and deleted them
after congress requested them and i
think they're looking at that too
i think so i think
can you imagine i have a friend he's
very smart rich guy made a lot of money
but he's a very streetwise guy
he said you know you've been under
investigation by these thieves
and they're smart they just weren't
smart when they all used the same exact
method
to clean their phone that wasn't smart
you know
at least put it in a little bit there 31
different phones
like what is it 21 people 31 phones
but that's okay that's okay that's only
that's only illegal but this friend of
mine said you know
they've gone through everything they've
gone through your taxes they've gone
through your
financials they've gone through
everything you have to be the most
honest guy in the world and they come up
no collusion oh they want to if they
found
if they found anything now it's a bad
group of people headed by
robert mueller bad group of people
who wanted the job at the fbi but he
lied to congress he said he didn't say
that but he did i mean he did
we have all the proof so he is in the
same group you know but they're actually
in worse shape
because at least with mueller you can
say he probably didn't know what the
hell he was doing
sort of like joe biden
i figured about about the same does that
make sense is anybody
how would you like to you're getting a
divorce or something and you say
i gotta be represented by bob mueller
do you think so you saw his performance
in congress right
i want to be represented by bob mueller
now it's the same thing
how can we have joe biden
representing this country
and you know he's he's on the lid you
know the lid right the lid is what they
say
we're going to put a lid on it so i
guess it means probably what it's
supposed i have no idea
it's a little but it's an expression and
every day
early in the morning they say joel joe
i mean joe biden sleepy joey's put a lid
on it sir
biden has put a lid on it what does that
mean that means he's not working today
this guy takes more days off you have to
have
a president that's going to work his ass
off in this country
you need energy you need a very
energetic
president
they said how do you think he's going to
do in the debate i think good he's been
doing it for 47 years i think he's going
to do good
i think and one thing we know if he does
just
okay just okay they're going to say the
fake news they're going to say it was
the single
greatest debate performance in history
it was unbelievable far better than
winston churchill and his pride
winston churchill was nothing compared
to sleepy joe
so you know that if he finishes the
debate if he finishes
which i think he will and he might even
do well
but if he does well they're going to say
it's the greatest debate for and they
haven't already written
they have a couple of scenarios if he
does really poorly they're going to say
he wasn't bad
he wasn't bad if he does modestly well
like he did against bernie they were
sort of even
if he does like that they'll say it was
the greatest performance in history
but with your vote i will preserve our
constitution
and ensure law and order
[Applause]
joe biden is weak he surrendered his
party to the flag burners the rioters
the anti-police anarchists the
radicals all these guys running around
these
these democrat run cities and states
look at it
ten out of ten we could fix up portland
so fast they have to invite us
and i want to be invited into that one
would we would fix that like we did
minneapolis
we would fix that up in in less than a
half an hour
remember minneapolis they were right i
mean the problem is they invited us in
about two weeks
by the time they invited there was a lot
of flames behind him remember the
reporter he's standing there
this is a peaceful protest
and behind him you have like blocks it
looked like berlin during the war didn't
it
i never said anything this is the
craziest thing it's a peaceful
performance
but what we did we said it's a peaceful
protest
and we don't call these rallies anymore
because in
dem states like where you have a
governor who's a democrat
you're not allowed to go to church
you're not allowed to go to a restaurant
you're not allowed to go to your
friend's house
you can't move from your house unless
you're related to the governor then you
can do whatever the hell you want
you can't do anything you can't do
anything unless
of course it's a peaceful protest
okay and
so what we do is we call these peaceful
protests so we're getting big crowds 25
30
000 35 000. there's more enthusiasm now
than there was four years ago because
we've done a good job
right there's more now
now we have more enthusiasm now that we
did you know it's interesting don't
forget four years ago
i did a nice job i was successful had a
great television show the apprentice it
was great
people got to know me a little bit i
said let me run from the
time the first hour that we came down
the escalator first lady and i down the
escalator her with a white dress right
very famous escalator right now people
go take pictures of the escalator
but we came down the escalator we were
in first place right
we never went i never left center stage
right
and that's based on poll numbers if
you're the number one polar
and i said look i want an odd number
i don't want an even number because it
was what are you talking i said because
that means two people are in center and
that's not fair
so i want an odd number we were on
center stage
but we've done a good job what happened
is i came i said i was going to cut your
taxes
we gave you the biggest tax decrease in
history
i said i was going to cut regulations
and we were going to have an incredible
economy and regulations were probably
even
more important than the tax cuts okay
you want to know the truth
you ask the business people the great
ones they will tell you if they had a
choice i'll take the regulation cuts
and we still have ways to go with that
but we did that
we rebuilt your military we added space
force i mean what we've done
is far more far more
right to try how about right to try i
never talked about that
i never talked about it we knocked out
100
of the isis caliphate right
we achieved energy independence and
we've done it while protecting our
very pristine environment by the way
and earlier this month oh you're going
to be so happy virginia
and north carolina come on
north carolina you're going to be so
happy you're going to be cheering like
crazy because i think you like this
but about a month ago i signed an order
prohibiting
offshore drilling on the florida georgia
and south carolina cause right
right and because i happen to like this
state a lot i said
what about virginia what about
north carolina and somebody said i don't
know i don't know if they
like it i said i think they like it so
i'm extending the moratorium to north
carolina and virginia
and if you want to have oil rigs out
there just let me know we'll take it off
i mean you know i can understand that
too i can understand that too but i
think you want it so we're extending it
to virginia
we're extending it to north carolina up
the coast and we're not going to have
any problems like
can be had all right so i think you like
that
you don't like it you're going to let me
know i'm going to change it i can change
things very easily
we built the greatest economy in the
history of the world and now we're
quickly doing it again so
i did all of these things and in doing
all these things you said
the second time well now this is
actually a much easier
campaign in a way the only problem is
i've been tarred
with this horrible witch hunt for four
years
and i didn't do it now think of it
what would my numbers be if i didn't go
through almost four years of a russian
witch-hunt
that turned out to be just the opposite
they were the ones that were involved
with russia
it was a whole big disinformation
campaign
now what would my numbers be with all
that we've done and if you didn't hear
night after
night on fake news cnn and msdnc
and the new york times and the
washington post and now it's turning out
not turning out it's done
because if you look at everything that's
come out over the last few days
it's we caught them they've been caught
they spied on my campaign
and they tried for a coup can you
believe it in this day and age
and we caught him called so what would
our numbers be our numbers not mine
what would our numbers be if every night
every morning every day they were saying
russia russia russia
it turned out to be a total hoax in fact
biden's son it was just revealed two
days ago
got three and a half million dollars
from the wife of the mayor of moscow
think of it so
but i really think about that what would
be on that we did all these
incredible things with the economy with
everything then we got hit
with this virus from china they should
never have let it happen we won't forget
it
and we closed up we saved millions of
lives now we've opened it with opening
to records but
what would our popularity be if every
day for
almost four years you didn't hear any of
this
[ __ ] okay what would it be
[Applause]
it's true what would they be
with all we've done i think that would
be very nice the democrats would say yes
if you'd like we could cancel the
election because we have no chance
but you know what hopefully they have no
chance anyway and hopefully you're going
to remember what i just said
because we were unjustly treated
unjustly accused by a bunch of
treasonous crooks
a bunch of bad bad people who got
caught and i think they'll have to pay a
very substantial price
[Applause]
when the plague arrived from china we
launched the largest national
mobilization since world war
ii we pioneered life-saving therapies
reducing the fatality rate
85 since april you know
the question was asked to me how well
did we do
on the pandemic and i said i give us an
a to an a plus you look at the
ventilators you look at all we've done
we did a great job we helped the
governors the governors are always very
thankful then sometimes they'll get in
front of a camera they'll remember some
of them but democrats right
but i said the only thing we did badly
on was public relations
because we were working so hard we
didn't think i think
frankly they're not going to cover it
well no matter what
but we did a hell of a job and then
compare us to europe and we did very
well
but now that europe is exploding again
they don't want to talk about it and
neither do i because i want you
i want europe to heal i want the whole
world to heal
but we've done a hell of a job except in
public relations and that's explaining
it to people
on that i give us a d but we got an a
plus in terms of what we've done through
operation
warp speed we will develop and
distribute a vaccine in record time
by the end of the year and it could be
sooner than that but we have
the greatest labs the greatest companies
of that kind
in the world and they are right there
they are right there it's going to be
incredible so
it's going to be a great vaccine and we
have
kizer johnson and johnson moderna
another one just announced today these
are great
great great companies on november 3rd
virginia will decide
whether we end the pandemic and return
to record prosperity or whether we allow
joe biden to kill the recovery
delay the vaccine impose a four
trillion dollar tax hike on you that's
what he wants to do
ban american energy he wants to ban
fracking how about that
he wants to ban fracking then he lucks
into the nomination you know he
shouldn't have gotten it
because if pocahontas left two days
early
bernie would have won and we would have
had bernie i don't know who i would have
been better
against maybe who knows but we would
have had radical bernie
but we're going to get a lot of birdie
votes like we did last night because
his people agree with us on trade except
we're better at it than he is
so we're going to get a lot of the
bernie votes boy bernie takes a hard
shot doesn't he this is twice that
happened and he
has such a nice attitude between him and
how about bloomberg
bloomberg gets absolutely decimated in
the debate right
minnie mike minnie mine mini mike
he gets decimated and in order to get
back with the democrat party
i'm gonna put a hundred million dollars
into florida if i were him i just
just take a pass he doesn't have to give
us anything we don't need his money
just take a pass you know so he wants to
buy his way into the democrats
and so he's going down to florida it's
but unfortunately he did something that
wasn't so good right
he said i'm gonna pay off all these
fines of the prisoners there's only one
problem it's illegal
now he's got himself a problem now he's
got himself a bigger problem than he had
when pocahontas beat the hell out of him
in the debate
oh that wasn't so easy remember she was
going point after point after point
and he thought she was talking about me
and so did i actually and then
and then what happened she said and i'm
not talking about president trump i'm
talking about you and he went oh my god
he's not a good guy's a not a good guy
stupid to do that stupid you have to
have some pride you can't go with the
way they treated him so badly you can't
do that
but they're going to destroy the suburbs
you know i keep hearing about
suburban women like you right suburban
women well
i just ended a regulation that would
have allowed projects
in your do you mind having a project
next to your house you're beautiful you
live in a beautiful house right
happily married beautiful kids
everything perfect the american dream
right
do you mind having a project built next
door
she said she minds you know who minds
everybody minds i just don't think
anybody knows that we did this i really
don't i don't think anybody knows
and they're going to change the zoning
that allows them
to build projects in the suburbs so the
guys came to me i said i want to end
that they came sir we're all set
we're going to really bring it back i
said no i didn't say bring it back i
said i wanted any well that's not so
easy
i said i want it ended i don't want it i
don't want it
and we terminated it so you can live
happily ever after if you vote for trump
if you don't vote for trump you can
forget it because they will put you know
who's in charge of it cory booker
senator cory booker he's another beauty
he was elizabeth if you if you really
think he had elizabeth warren yet cory
booker
and you had kamala you know if you
pronounce her name wrong she goes crazy
come on
like a comma it's like a comma she's
like a comma
and by the way nobody treated sleepy joe
worse than his vice presidential fan i
brilliantly said
he'll never pick kamala because he got
treated he got called a racist
he got called xenophobic which he didn't
know what that meant
he got called all sorts of things right
and so i said no obviously he's not
going to be he picked her i couldn't
believe it but i think that's good
we like our mike pence we like mike
[Applause]
and she's rated further left
than bernie sanders i thought he was the
most left in the
he's not actually even in the party he's
sort of like an independent
nobody ever used to say that but he's
like an independent but she's rated
further left
than crazy bernie and uh
this is what you want i don't think so
just so you understand
if and then she calls it the harris
administration
along with just like you're naming a
movie the producing credits right
in the harris administration along with
uh vice president biden
no no no he's heading up the ticket but
then he said the same thing
he put her name first i've never done
that i love mike but i've never said
mike pence and donald trump i always say
trump because you know what
you got to know that you're the
president he doesn't know
that he's in first position he doesn't
know it
he doesn't know it he forgot he forgot
hey look you're entitled to a mistake
every once in a while
it was strange that they did it almost
in the same hour though right
it was like one on top of another give
free health care they want to give free
health care to illegal aliens
and indoctrinate your children with
poisonous anti-american lies in school
we don't like that
to combat the toxic and you see what it
is
it's toxic left-wing propaganda in our
schools i announced last week that we
are launching a new pro-american lesson
plan for students
called the 1776 commission
we will teach our children the truth
about america that we are the most
exceptional nation on the face of the
earth and we're getting
better better better all the time
and we're joined tonight by a friend of
ours a warrior congressman
rob whitman
good guy virginia republican party chair
rich anderson good job
how are we doing am i making the right
move
i'm not wasting my time here rich i got
to ask him rich what do you think i
think so right
i think so and congressional candidates
nick freitas
oh look at him we had a call the other
day very successful call right
great call thanks nick and a real
warrior real hero
scott taylor
[Applause]
those are two very important races and i
think you're going to win them i saw
some good polling
we're taking over the house from crazy
nancy we're going to have it
and i think those two guys i think
they're going to win also
somebody that i have heard incredible
things about
the republican nominee for the u.s
senate daniel gage
[Applause]
he's a good-looking guy
and i'll tell you he's got to beat his
opponent because he is
just warner warner was you know he was
talking about russia right
trump and russia russia russia then he
gets scammed
by a guy with the greatest russian
accent you remember that right
i have pictures of president trump
oh really where where where what are
they like are they nude pictures yes yes
yes
there's vladimir no yes yes yes so he's
talking to this guy he got scammed okay
i was a comedian or something
he was a comedian he's allowed to talk
to russians if i talk to a russian it's
a terrible
thing by the way you know getting along
with russia is not the worst thing in
the world does that make sense
getting along with north korea kim
jong-un everyone said oh
he's getting along he's giving so much i
said what did he give
they couldn't tell me anything you know
what i gave sanctions that's what i get
but you know what we get along we get
along you would have been in a war right
now would have been a nuclear war you
would have been a war right now
with north korea but was it for me
hillary clinton didn't have a clue
obama didn't have a clue obama told me
when i sat with him the one time i sat
with him what's your biggest problem
north korea
i said how big he said it's a big
problem and he was indicating like it
was war
i said have you tried calling him have
you tried have you given it a little
shot
you know instead of losing 10 million
people they used to say
50 000 people could be killed no 20
million people could be killed okay
20 million seoul is right next to you
know right near the border
it would be uh too bad but we have a
good relationship i get criticized
because i have relationships with these
people
and that's a positive thing we have to
remember that's a positive thing
and i had a very good relationship in
china with president xi but you know
what this pandemic has just
we've made a great trade deal but it
just doesn't mean the same to me does
that make any sense it doesn't mean
it doesn't mean the same to me last week
two weeks ago they had the largest order
of corn
to our farmers in our history they had
the largest order of soybeans
they had this massive order of beef
but you know what it does just doesn't
mean
as much to me now as it did at one point
the ink wasn't even dry on the trade
deal
and this thing came in and they could
have stopped it we're also deeply moved
to be joined by two gold star spouses
two incredible people
karen owens was a guest at my first
address to congress as we honor the
supreme sacrifice of her husband
fallen navy seal ryan owens where's
come on up here come up
and we're also joined with brittany
jacobs and her family you know brittany
on memorial day in 2017 i met brittany
and her son christian
at arlington national cemetery and we
honored the memory of her
incredible husband and christian's dad
marine sergeant christopher jacobs we
took a
picture together that little boy who's
no longer a little boy
come on over here come on come on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
i said how's your beautiful handsome boy
she said really good but
he wants to go back to school let's go
open up the schools
open up the schools we'll get them often
but we thank god every day for our
courageous warriors and will always
support
our incredible ghosts our families that
we want to thank both of you it's
incredible thank you
and we'll get you back to school soon
all right get them back come on governor
let's go we got other things to do
these people you know they're keeping
the states closed because they think
it's going to be harmful
on november 3rd and it's that really
it's not going to have too much of an
impact what it's doing is hurting a lot
of people though it's hurting a lot of
people
in everything we do we are putting
america first
we've spent the last four years
reversing the terrible damage
joe biden and his friends inflicted on
this country over the last
47 years i love it when he says
we could have done this we should have
done that the guy's been here forever
47 years hard to believe right and that
was in prime time although he never had
super prime time but that was in prime
time remember
and this time and now i got them here
together we've taken on a corrupt
and broken system that's been throwing
everything at us from the very beginning
a new trove of documents and you have to
go home you got to read these documents
and they now prove that russia
interfered in 2016.
unfortunately it was on behalf of
hillary clinton not trump
they interfered misinformation
newly released text messages make 100
clear the fbi knew that democrats
purchased russian disinformation
targeting me your favorite president
[Applause]
which then formed the basis for the
witch hunt
and i'll tell you we've had some
incredible strength
in terms of people like sean hannity
the great lou dobbs thank you laura
tucker tucker's been great the last
fox and friends janine
janine i'll tell you
jesse how about jessie
hey greg gutfeld was bad to me now he's
great to me
he said hey would you rather have a nice
guy that doesn't do anything or a
horrible human being like trump that
gets it done
they all say i'd rather have the
horrible you i'm not a horrible unit
i'm a nicer guy i always get very
offended when they say about like
well maybe people don't like him but he
gets everything done i think people like
me but i do get it done
[Music]
[Applause]
and more than any administration
ever in three and a half years
i'll tell you that is so nice that is so
nice the first you talk about the
seating we're gonna don't worry about
uh the justice will get her seat don't
worry about that
and that's a nice outside but you know
they say these people said they've never
heard
a political campaign where a big
audience says
we love trump or the candidate
i've never heard it i've never heard it
it's true i've never heard it for ronald
reagan and i like ronald reagan but i've
never heard it
and they've never heard it nobody's ever
heard it who says that
but i love you too i really do i do
and we're getting it done no they've
never heard that chant i've never heard
it
and it started about two weeks ago i've
never heard it even before but
again before
i want to thank you it's really nice
it's really nice and we've got to go out
and we've got to really work hard
and we've got to watch this ballot scam
because they're scamming us
okay they're scamming us and then they
say he doesn't want to turn over again
of course they do
but it's got to be a fair election you
know see that's
that's another scam they don't mention
anything about ballots i say
got to be a fair election when they're
losing ballots all over the place
when they're losing ballots they just
happen to be trump ballots
you know in virginia did you hear in a
very democrat area
they sent two ballots to thousands of
people a thousand or thousands of people
it just came out over the wires
so people in a democrat area got two
ballots instead of one
this is they had eight ballots and a
waste paper basket
military ballots that all were for trump
everyone was for trump
and they were in a waste paper basket
they were thrown away and somebody saw
him
then they had many many ballots thrown
into a river
someplace i don't even know the state
these are just a few of them
and then go back earlier go back to the
democrat primaries go back to the great
state
iowa i love iowa we're going to win iowa
big big big big
we won it last time by 11 points we're
gonna win it big with ethanol what i've
done for them with the 28 billion
dollars for the farmers
and that includes you that includes
tobacco that includes a lot of things
but that includes
your farmers but you go back to their
primaries right
go back to the primary the iowa the
first
primary it was done with ballots they
have no idea remember the disaster
and that's a small primary now they're
talking about
tens of millions of these fake ballots
going all over the place
who's sending them where are they being
sent
who's sending them back supposing they
don't get them
are they being sent to democrat areas
and they're all
run by democrat governors right all of
them 100 percent
it's 100 so you have a guy in nevada
he just comes up with the idea i love i
think we're going to win nevada
if fairly we're going to win it but he
comes up well you don't have to have
your signature verified oh that's nice
that's good he decided let's not do that
but you know a real big problem i like
watching television
and have the winner is right
you might not hear it for months because
this is a mess
go back and study what happened in iowa
take a look
take a look at what happened in new york
in a small congressional race carolyn
maloney she should have lost the race in
my opinion
they gave it to her because it was a
crooked deal the guy
the guy that she ran against was having
fits he said what are you doing
what are you doing everything was mixed
up the ballots were lost there was fraud
there was everything
going to paterson new jersey these are
just recently
it's a disaster waiting to happen
and the only one that knows it better
than we do are the democrats they know
this is going to happen
they want it to happen because they want
to go through a court system
and instead you're not going to hear
very unlikely that you're going to hear
winner that night
i could be leading and then they'll just
keep getting ballots and ballots and
ballots and ballots
because now they're saying that the
ballots can come in late well what does
that mean
and more importantly they're going to be
given in some cases a week or two weeks
to count the ballots so if we're waiting
for one state
now think of it if we're waiting this is
they're talking about five six seven
states that have this problem
so if we're waiting for one state does
that mean the whole nation the whole
world is gonna wait for
one state i won't use any names but you
have pennsylvania where you have a
democrat who by the way lost the case
last week
we sued we want him to open up his state
and we won
on constitutional ground
north carolina they have the state all
locked up so
we're talking about these are the
governors that run their states for
democrats they really do
i mean they run them they're democrat
governors and they're in charge of the
count
we went to nevada to make a speech we
had five different sites
the governor made it impossible so we
ended up at a different site we had to
get one very
this is the guy that's in charge of
ballots he was a political hack
now he's the governor and this guy is in
charge of ballots
it's not going to work it's going to be
a disaster and i want a smooth beautiful
transition
but they don't add the other part but
it's got to be an
honest vote and everybody knows just go
back again
look at iowa look what happened just
take a look at that
they still don't know who won they
didn't know weeks later remember
new hampshire went new hampshire
declared a winner
and essentially they don't know what
happened in iowa
except the difference is we're doing the
same thing but with tens of millions of
ballots
this is a disaster waiting to happen and
they shouldn't let this system
go if you ask for a ballot it's called
solicited you solicit you want the
ballot
it comes in you sign it you send it back
that's okay but where they send
millions and millions of unsolicited
ballots people get ballots they didn't
even know they were getting them
sign it sign it then they have people
going around getting it to sign
you know when you have that you don't
need it we have much more enthusiasm
we're so high up on enthusiasm right
[Applause]
but it's very unfair because when you
have somebody go knock on your door sign
it's called harvesting they're gonna
harvest ballots even though in some
cases in most cases
it's illegal it's illegal as hell and it
should be illegal
so this is a disaster waiting to happen
and the only hope we have really other
than going through a long
unbelievable litigation at the end after
it's over
because we're going to win we're not
going to lose this except if they cheat
that's the way i look at it
we can't let them cheat we can't let
them it's stupid our country
is at stake and it's true our country is
at stake
because these people will destroy our
country we can't let this happen
and this is a scam they know it the
media knows it
but the media doesn't want to cover it
they know exactly what's going to happen
and so do i
but the democrats know better than all
of us what's going to happen
so we can't let it and if you see
anything you just have to report it on
everything we're all watching law
enforcement's watching all over the
place
but it's very hard to watch you know
millions of ballots very hard to watch
and uh the only way we're gonna that's
the only way we're gonna lose
is if there's uh mischief
mischief and it'll have to be on a big
scale so be careful
and we do want a very friendly
transition
but we don't want to be cheated and be
stupid and say oh let's transit we'll
we'll go and we'll do a transition and
we know that there were
thousands and thousands of ballots that
made the difference
through cheating we're not going to
stand for it we're not going to stand
for it
so just remember keep your eyes open for
decades our opponents spent trillions of
dollars rebuilding other countries
and now we're finally rebuilding our
country
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s military all made in the usa
we launched the first new branch of the
armed forces
think of that since the air force 75
years ago it's called space force it's a
big deal
see that alone would be a big deal for
honestly that alone would be a very big
deal for
a administration we did think of it
we now have a sixth branch of the united
states armed forces that's a big deal
but we did so much more so much more i
mean think of it it's incredible
you know we did probably the most we'll
have maybe even more than 300
federal judges including court of
appeals and now we're going to have
three
supreme court judges their minds are
blowing
their minds you know you've had many
presidents never had one supreme court
judge we're gonna have three
of all people and that's a record of all
people
to get three supreme court justices
in one administration and one term
they are going crazy
they're saying darling tell me this is
not happening
but you'll see it tomorrow at five
o'clock with the help of the incredible
workers of newport news
and norfolk naval shipyards we will
build
355 we're going to have a
a navy again of 355 ships that's what we
need
that's been depleted and they're already
being built we got a
we've got a few big ones beauties being
built including aircraft carriers
biden will slash military funding and
ship building will be shut down it's
going to be shut down
like it used to be we killed the founder
and leader of isis
al-baghdadi
we took out the world's number one
terrorist and mass murderer
salamani i withdrew from last
administration's
disastrous iran nuclear catastrophe
what a deal that was 150 billion dollars
1.8 billion in cash
you ever see what 1.8 billion in cash
it's plain loads
these guys over there they must have
said what the hell is this
they never saw money like that we paid
you know we got for it
nothing nothing i kept my promise
recognized the true capital of israel
and opened the american
embassy in jerusalem
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
they've been working on that for 52
years i got it done quickly
and instead of endless wars we are
forging peace in the middle east we even
got
nominated right you know what for
that's right i hate to talk about it but
i have to because the press doesn't talk
about it
no it's uh it was a great honor it was a
great honor twice
you know that right the press doesn't
talk about
the nobel peace prize right two for
different things
for kosovo and serbia we stopped them
from killing each other it was very nice
and they don't have to kill each other
they've been killing each other for a
long time kosovo serbia was great
it was great and we got a nomination for
israel and you look at bahrain uae
that's just the beginning we have them
lined up that want to go into that well
peace in the middle east without blood
all over
the sand
and i told you you heard the story i
went home i said first lady i'm gonna
get the greatest stories tonight
i just got nominated for the nobel
peace prize first lady
to israel everybody said it couldn't be
done
and they were right it couldn't be done
the way they were doing it you would
have never gotten it done the way john
kerry was doing it you would have never
gotten it
as a guy doesn't have a clue incompetent
but you know what
i said first lady where do you see this
it's going to be unbelievable
and we watched lester halt i don't even
know why
and we had one story after another after
another
and after seven stories i said first
lady this is getting a little
embarrassing
and they never mentioned that nor did
any other
of the newscasts fake cnn didn't mention
it
msdnc didn't match
abc cbs nobody mentioned it so i was
very embarrassed three days later i got
nominated again
[Applause]
and i said my great first lady
we got another shot at it darling let's
watch the news tonight
one story two stories three stories four
stars five senses
we got to the end it wasn't mentioned
again and when barack hussein obama
was nominated it was
and he didn't know what he got it for he
still doesn't
he doesn't know what he got it so we
have a little double standard going but
that's okay
as long as we know sometimes i'll be
talking that way and i'll look around
i'll say
oh i'm in the oval office how did that
happen
i said you know with all the complaining
we're in the oval office and they're not
right let's keep it that way so we can
keep this going
[Applause]
we've achieved more
in 47 months than joe biden has achieved
in 47 years
it's true
biden without even knowing it is pushing
the most far left platform in history
the biden plan would destroy social
security and destroy protection
for people with pre-existing conditions
he would terminate our travel bans and
jihadist regions you know i got the
travel ban remember everyone said you
couldn't do that
i want a travel ban from people
that want to blow up our country do you
think that's okay
people said oh we don't like that took a
little heat and we got it they said i
didn't get it and they were right we
lost at one court lost in the second
then we won
in the supreme court they don't say that
but we have a strong travel ban
and we will use it we do use it we use
it plenty
and increase refugee admissions they
want to increase refugee admission
700 opening the floodgates for
radical islamic terrorism they want to
ban school choice in charter schools in
the second term
i will provide school choice to every
parent in america
a vote for republicans is the vote for
safe communities great jobs
and a limitless future for all americans
it's so
true and in conclusion i love you people
but i've been doing this since early in
the morning i'm getting the hell out of
here
i would only do this for you i got a guy
who stays in his damn basement all day
long and i'm doing this
i don't know if he wins i'm going to be
very embarrassed i'll say d i worked so
hard and he didn't work at all
now we're going to win i think we're
going to win i think we're going to win
big i think we're going to i think we're
going to win bigger than anyone
understands i think there's a vote out
there
there's a hidden vote out there the
pulses are fake they're controlled by
the same people the right
the bad stories the fake stories over
the next four
years we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults from law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
bannon
[Applause]
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
virginia
we will strike down terrorists who
threaten our citizens and we will keep
america out of the ridiculous
horrible endless foreign wars countries
that you've never even heard of
we will keep you out of them and by the
way we have weapons the likes of which
nobody has ever seen before
we have a level of the degree of which
nobody from
russia to china to north korea nobody's
ever seen what we built
and just hope to god we never have to
use them but we have never had anything
like
the arsenal that we've built over the
last three years
hope to god we never have to use them
we're the envy of the world in that way
we have the greatest we have the
greatest people for
billy there's nobody can do what we can
do there's nobody but
when i came in your military was totally
depleted you had old planes you had old
everything
we have now the f-35s and
we have things the bombers the new
bombers the tankers the
ships that we're building some right
here newport news
you know
but we have built an arsenal the likes
of which the world has never seen
and you know what that will make it a
lot easier for us
not to have to use them that's really
what we need we needed it we were in bad
shape
we were in bad shape we will maintain
america's unrivaled military
might and we will ensure peace through
strength and that's what we've done
we will end surprise medical buildings
require price
transparency and further reduce health
insurance you know the health insurance
is a
disaster and we are bringing the price
of health insurance way down premiums
and costs of
prescription drugs we're instituting
favored nations
we pay the highest in the world for
drugs i negotiated with big pharma
and i just got tired of negotiating i
said i'm sorry
we're instituting favored nations we're
the largest purchaser
of prescription drugs by far in the
world and i
instituted what we call a favorite
nations laws
where we will pay the same price as the
nation
that pays the lowest price in the world
in addition to that i instituted a
rebate clause where we get the rebates
instead of the middlemen these are the
richest people
i don't know who the hell they are but
the middlemen are they're very rich and
they're not liking me too much and
you're going to see a lot of bad ads
from big pharma they've already started
just remember every time you see one of
those ads that means your drug prices
are coming way down
and i mean by 50 60 70 and 80 percent
we'll strongly protect medicare and
social security we will always protect
patients with pre-existing conditions
always
always america will land the first woman
on the moon in the united states will be
the first nation to land an
astronaut on mars
and we've taken nasa from fairways gray
or i mean you have to see they had
fairways along like a golf course it was
a better golf course than it was a
runway and what we've done we've taken
all the grass out
it was grass growing right through the
cracks it was a disgrace
and we've now made it the number one
space center in the world
by far again
you ought to see this they were playing
golf
they were playing golf it was all closed
up or essentially closed up
it was actually worse than closed up you
know what it was sort of open but nobody
was doing anything they had nothing to
do we had the greatest scientists in the
world
and we're letting rich guys send up
rockets we like it somehow rich people
like to set rockets up
we say just pay us a nice rent and have
a lot of fun sending your rockets up
but nasa is now number one in the world
again
by far and there's no contest
and all that grass is gone
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore patriotic
education to our schools
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag are you listening nfl
are you listening nfl
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
virginia
and north carolina
[Applause]
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors
get your co-workers and get out and
vote there's never been a more important
election than this
election early voting has already begun
do not wait go out and vote
from richmond to roanoke from frederick
burgs to williamsburg
and from norfolk to right here in
newport news
we stand on the shoulders of virginia
patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears for
this beloved nation
virginia is the place that gave us
george washington
thomas jefferson james madison
james monroe now you know
uh i signed a little document 10 years
in prison
if you knock down a statue or a monument
[Applause]
it's amazing how you haven't seen any of
that lately
they were having a little fun and now
they were heading toward the jefferson
memorial i said wait a minute
and i predicted that they were knocking
down statues a lot of people didn't know
exactly which
one i said you better stop it because
the next thing you know they'll knock
down the statue of robert e lee and they
did
i said you better stop it or they'll be
going after thomas jefferson
and washington and abe lincoln and they
started
and i said what are we going to do here
i have some good people
they said you know because today in
congress you can't get anything done
they'd give you
one day in in a very nice hotel
so i said what are we going to do they
said we'll take out an old
we'll take out an old law and you can
reinstitute it with an executive order i
said what does it say
10 years in prison not jail they use the
word prison
i said for what you knocked down a
monument or a statue you go to jail for
10 years i said
give me that thing get it to my office
and i signed it and they were coming
down to washington they were going to
knock down two particular statues that
were
really beautiful and i signed it and we
announced it had a news conference got
to let people know about it right
and the 20 000 person march turned out
to be about three people
two of them were arrested actually
because we have thanks to the fake news
we have a lot of footage of people
standing on
the statue of jackson andrew jackson
remember they almost had the ropes we
sent in the police the police did a
great job by the way
remember that the ropes are ready to
pull it down and we said
charge and they charged and i want to
tell you they did a hell of a job
they were much tougher than the people
with the ropes
it took them about two minutes and that
was the end of the ropes but it was
klaus they got there just in time
but you know what since i signed that
there's been no statues no monuments
that have been played with it
federal federal states have to do the
same thing for their states
virginia heroes made america into the
single greatest nation in the history of
the world
and the best is yet to come
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning
power to you the american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive we are going to keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting and we
are going to keep on
winning winning winning
but a win win win
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god and
together
with the incredible people of virginia
and north carolina
we will make america wealthy again
we will make america strong again
we will make america proud again
we will make america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you virginia thank you
get out and vote
thank you
[Music]
and i'm sure
[Music]
which one is
[Music]
[Music]
was once in your shoes
me
is
[Music]
don't kill me
[Music]
wow
me
oh
blue
[Music]
i foreign
[Music]
always will be dancing
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
is
[Music]
let them know she says
[Music]
and you can hear me
slowly
on the highway
[Music]
is
[Music]
happy birthday
15 days
[Music]
i
[Music]
you must
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
when i say
[Music]
[Music]
dancing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where are you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh